TWO ON NATURAL RESOURCES.
BARBARA PROTECTION ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION SUPPORT.
I'M OUR FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS
IS THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR THIS
COULD BE ISSUES NUMBER. ONE
THROUGH -- FOURTEEN WE DO HAVE A
REQUEST FROM -- CENTER MCGUIRE
IN SENATOR MINING TO REMOVE
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR SO WE'RE GOING
TO REMOVE ISSUE NUMBER FOUR FOR
VOTE ONLY AND MOVED ON TO THE
DISCUSSION -- THERE HAS BEEN A
NEW SHEET THAT SHOULD BE OF IS
AVAILABLE -- THERE'S COPIES ON
ISSUE NUMBER -- SIXTEEN WHAT ARE
THE THREE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND -- THERE'S BEEN
SOME CHANGES IN THE SENATE.
FIRST UP TO SEE --
RECOMMENDATION AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW THE AUCTION WAS HELD
YESTERDAY.
THE ANTICIPATION IS THAT THERE
WILL BE AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE OF THE
AMBITIOUS.
A SCHEDULED AT THIS THE SENATE
HAS SAID SO THAT IS IF YOU'RE
DOING THE MATH AND SAYING THIS
DOESN'T ADD UP THAT'S THE THE
CALCULATIONS THAT WERE WERE
MAKING -- AS SO WITH THAT DO WE
HAVE [inaudible]
SEE.
I WILL HAVE. THREE MOTIONS.
ON APPROVING FOR VOTE ONLY ON
APPROVAL OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION THE GENDERS.
THIS MOTION NUMBER ONE WOULD BE.
ISSUES ONE THROUGH ONE G..
ISSUE FIVE TO TEN ISSUE TWELVE
AN ISSUE THIRTEEN IS THERE A
MOTION.
CENTER JONES YES IS MOTION BY
SENATOR JONES.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND LET'S
ESTABLISH A CORE.
I CAN'T HEAR JONES -- PLAN.
MORNING.
DURING.
I'D A QUORUM HAVING BEEN
ESTABLISHED THERE'S A MOTION BY --
CENTER JONES.
THIS CALL THE ROLL.
I CAN SEE HI.
DOWNS [inaudible]
MONEY -- FOR VOTES WILL KEEP THE
MATTER OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
MOTION NUMBER TWO WILL BE ISSUE
NUMBER TWO AND ISSUE NUMBER
FIFTEEN IS THERE A MOTION ON
THOSE TWO ISSUES.
ISSUE NUMBER TWO AND FIFTEEN
THERE'S A MOTION BY SENATOR
MINING.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WE CASTING
I CAN [inaudible]
WITH PLAN [inaudible]
MONEY.
CENTER JONES I DIDN'T QUITE HEAR
YOU WAS SAID AND NOT VOTING OR
NOT VOTING OKAY SO THE MOTION.
DOES THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE THE
AYES HAVE IT FOR TWO ZERO WITH
ONE NOT VOTING LET'S GOOD ISSUE
IN MOTION NUMBER THREE THIS TO
BE.
CENTER STERN ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM THE VOTE
ON THE CALENDAR -- WE ARE NOW
MOTION NUMBER THREE IS.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN AND ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN
IS THERE A MOTION FOR THOSE
MATTERS.
IS A MOTION BY CENTER STERN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I CASTING I DON'T KNOW
[inaudible]
PLAN [inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
LOS ROLE TELL YOU BOTH THE I
SEVEN FORTY ONE LET'S OPEN THE
ROLE IN MOTION NUMBER ONE WHICH
SHOULD BE ISSUES.
ONE THROUGH ONE G. ISSUES FIVE
BODY A CHANCE TO REVIEW THE
MODIFIED -- GREENHOUSE GASES WE
WILL TAKE A SHORT RECESS NOW AND
THEN RETURNED TO BRING UP ISSUE
NUMBER
FOUR ALL RIGHT WE LIKE TO CALL
THE SUBCOMMITTEE BACK TOGETHER --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE WE
WILL NOW CALL UP -- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORCING FIRE
PROTECTION THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR ON THE ENHANCE FIRE
PROTECTION.
RESOURCES THE GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL -- FOR NINETY SIX POINT
NINE MILLION FROM GENERAL FUND
AND TWO POINT ONE REIMBURSEMENTS
FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS FUND.
AN OFFSETTING REDUCTIONS TO THE
CALLS AND DO CAN REIMBURSEMENT
FUND THERE IS STAFF
RECOMMENDATION LANGUAGE ABOUT
REPORTING ON THE WELL IN THE
HEALTH AND WELLNESS -- PROGRAM.
THIS IS ON PAGE. FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN OF OUR REPORT THIS ISSUE.
ISSUE NUMBER -- FOUR CAL FIRE
WELCOME.
EARNING A JANET BERENSON CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIE
CHIEF PORTER IS CURRENTLY IN THE
ASSEMBLY TESTIFYING ON ARMY
REVISION.
I HAVE BEEN -- HAVE YOU DO YOU
HAVE A COMMENT ON THE THE FOLLOW
UP LANGUAGE THAT STAFF IS ASKED
ON THE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
PROGRAM NO I THINK HE LANGUAGE
THAT SAYS SUGGESTED HERE IS
APPROPRIATE AND AND SOMETHING
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
AS TO THE COMMITTEE FOR A OF HOW
WELL OUR HEALTH AND WELLNESS
PROGRAM IS IS -- OF HELPING OUR
EMPLOYEES EXCELLENT [inaudible]
ELIA.
BRIAN RAN WITH LA -- AT NO WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THE
LANGUAGE SEEMS LIKE AN
APPROPRIATE ADDITION TO GET MORE
INFORMATION ON WHAT'S AN
EXPANDED EFFORT BY THE
DEPARTMENT.
OKAY LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE -- TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE ON ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR ENHANCE FIRE PROTECTION.
OKAY CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING BRING
IT BACK TO THE THE DAIS --
SENATE MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I DO
APPRECIATE.
HOW FIRED FROM THE FINANCING IN
FORD THIS ISSUE ON NUMBER FOUR
ELECTED THEIR SPEAK SPECIFICALLY
AND ONE ISSUE IN REGARDS?
TO THE THIRTEEN FIRE ENGINES
UNDER ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR I'M WHERE.
I THINK MANY OF OUR CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
MONTHS.
IN TAKING A LOOK AT THE FATIGUE
THAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE PAST
FOUR YEARS WITHIN THE RANKS OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE ONLY WAY THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO RESOLVE THIS CHALLENGE
AND I SAY IT'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES THIS
DEPARTMENT HAS EVER FACED IN ITS
HISTORY.
THE FATIGUE THAT BRAVE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO ARE GOING IN.
WHEN ALL ARE COMING OUT?
AND WHILE I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE
GOVERNOR ADVANCING THIRTEEN FIRE
ENGINES -- IT'S SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH.
THE STATE IS STILL UNDER THE
PEAK OF IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
OR THIRTY ONE ENGINE SHORT OF
WHERE WE WERE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE IN THE STATE -- SO
WHERE.
WHERE I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GO
IS A COMMITMENT? TO BE ABLE TO
SAY IT'S GOING TO BE THIRTEEN
THIS YEAR. THIRTEEN NEXT HI AND
THEN I AFTER THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR TO BE ABLE TO GET US TO
WHERE WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO GO
TO BE ABLE TO HELP THOSE.
WHO ARE?
AT FIFTEEN YOU HEAR IN THE RANKS
WITHIN THE DISTRICTS OF
CALIFORNIA EACH AND EVERY DAY.
HOW LONG THEY'RE GONE?
HOW IT'S IMPACTING THEMSELVES
AND IMPACT IN THE FAMILY?
SO THAT'S WHERE I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO GO OVER THE
NEXT. THIRTY SIX MONTHS IS
CONTINUE TO ADD THOSE THIRTEEN
ENGINES THIS YEAR.
NEXT YEAR AND THE YEAR AFTER I
TO BE ABLE TO GET US BACK TO
WHERE WE WERE IN NINETEEN
FLIPPIN SEVENTY FIVE BEFORE I
WAS BORN.
SO I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I HAVE NO COMMENT WHERE I WAS IN
[inaudible]
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE SENATOR
MINING.
IF YOU CAN REMEMBER YOU WEREN'T
THERE.
I JUS WANT TO ADD ON TO THE
COMMENTS OF SENATOR MCGUIRE.
I APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
WHAT'S IN FRONT OF US.
I ALSO SHARE THE CONCERN.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT?
STAFFING AND WHEN WE LOOK DOWN
TO THE EMPLOYEE WELLNESS AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT UNDER THE NEW
ABNORMAL AS GOVERNOR BROWN --
DESCRIBED IT OF EXTENDED FIRE
SEASONS EXTENDED WEATHER EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS.
IN TE RISK THAT WERE PUTTING
FIREFIGHTERS.
AT ON THE FRONT LINES.
THAT'S WHAT'S PROMPTED ADDING
THE EMPLOYEE WELLNESS PEACE.
UNDERSTANDING THAT MORE
FIREFIGHTERS HAVE DIED FROM
SUICIDE THAN ON THE FRONTLINE OF
FIRES THERE'S A TRAUMA NOT
DISSIMILAR FROM.
BEING AT WAR ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS WORK.
SO WHEN WE TRANSLATE.
ENGINES THIRTEEN TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS.
REDUCE STRESS FOR ALL
FIREFIGHTERS BY INCREASING NOT
JUST TRUCKS.
BUT STAFFING ON THE FIRE LINE SO.
I WANT TO JUST JOIN WITH SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND EXPRESSING MY
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
IN THE NEXT. TWO YEARS BEYOND
THIS BUDGET YEAR. FOR THIS
CONTINUED ENHANCEMENT OF NOT
JUST TENSIONS BUT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES.
WORKING WITH THEIR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS ON THE FRONT LINES IN A
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE THAT CENTER JONES.
THE CHAIRMAN AND I JUST WANT TO
VOICE MY MORE ON THAT AS WELL.
AND NOT LOOK FOR TO BEING BACK
HERE NEXT YEAR AND ADVOCATING
FOR MORE FIRE ENGINES AND
STAFFING AS WELL AS MOST FOLKS
REALIZE THAT MY DISTRICT IS ONE
OF THE HIGH FIRE ZONES AS WELL --
HAVING ONE OF THE TO WORST FIRES
TWO THOUSAND THREE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN ARE.
THERE IS STILL A GREAT RISK AND
WHEN MY FIREFIGHTERS TRAVELED
THE REST OF THE STATE. FOR A
EIGHT OTHER TALENTS SOME THE
FARTHEST DISTRICT DISTANCES AND
HOME AWAY FROM HOME THE MOST AND
I I THINK THAT THIS GOES.
TO HELPING.
FIRST OF ALL PROTECT A DEFENDANT
AND THEN HELPING OUR
FIREFIGHTERS RETURN HOME SOONER.
AND I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CENTER STERN.
I WANT TO ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH.
MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS
[inaudible]
AND JUST.
MAKE ONE NOTE WE'VE BEEN BEATING
HIS DRUM I THINK ALL YEAR TALK
WITH LA -- ABOUT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
RIGHT SIZING THE SCOPE OF OUR
RESILIENCY BUDGET OVERALL
WHETHER IT'S ON THE SUPPRESSION
SIDE ON PREVENTION SIDE LOOKING
IN MITIGATION.
I THINK WE NEED OVERALL A RESET
ABOUT.
WHAT IS A LOT OF IT WHAT'S A LOT
AND WHAT ISN'T AND I FRANKLY
THINK ALL THIS IS UNDERSIZED THE
FACT THEY WERE FORCED TO TO SORT
OF FIGHT IN THESE?
NARROW POTS FOR FUNDING WHEN
THIS IS THE BIGGEST CRISIS STATE
BUSINESS DATA CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
CHANGES HERE.
NOT GOING ANYWHERE TO ACTUALLY
GOING TO GET WORSE SO -- FULLY
SUPPORT THAT BUT JUST IN THIS
BROADER CONTEXT IS AS WE GO
THROUGH THE GREENHOUSE GAS
PRODUCTION FUND WE LOOK AT OUR
PRICE OF CARBON AND WHERE IT IS
RIGHT NOW IN THIS STATE WHICH IS
ACTUALLY NOT THE SOCIAL COST OF
CARBON SEXY HALF OF WHAT.
THE TRUE COST OF CARBON IS AND
MORE BROADLY ABOUT OUR
STRATEGIES AND RESILIENCY FUNNY
I THINK THERE'S A WAY TO LIFT.
ALL ENGINES AND THE REST OF IT
AT THE SAME TIME BUT WE'RE GONNA
NEED THAT ANALYSIS SO.
JUST.
AS THERE BEEN ANY FURTHER
THINKING IN AT A DEAL WHERE FOR
AT IT AND ELLIE -- OR EVEN I
KNOW WE HAVE -- P. R. HERE TODAY
AS WELL.
WHAT THE SORT OF HOW TO HAVE A
PROPER NEEDS ASSESSMENT AND
WHETHER WERE ACTUALLY UNDER
SHOOTING ALL OF THIS?
STEPHEN BENSON DEPARTMENT FINDS
LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT IN A
PREVIOUS HEARING.
HOW FIRE IS AS A KIND OF A?
SPIN OFF BUT IT IS A PART OF THE
THE STRATEGIC PLAN THEY FINISH
THEIR GOING TO BE STARTING TO
WORK ON KIND OF THE LARGER.
ASSESSMENT OF THE OVERALL
STATEWIDE NEED MORE THAN MAYBE
GAPS AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE LOOK FORWARD -- TO
TO TRY AND GET TO THIS KIND OF
RIGHT SIZING CONCEPT -- I THINK.
CAN BUILDING OFTEN COMMENT YOU
MADE TO ME IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OVERALL
FRAMEWORK FOR THE BUDGET WAS
THAT OF RESILIENCY WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
WHEN WE DO ONGOING INVESTMENTS
WERE KIND OF KEEPING IN LINE
WITH WHAT THE ON GOING REVENUE
LOOKS LIKE AND I THINK THE LAST
THING YOU WANT TO DO IS INVEST?
IN A BUNCH OF THESE TYPES OF
RESOURCES AND THEN FIND OUT
ECONOMY SLOWS DOWN AND NOW WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
THINGS OUT OF THE BUDGET.
WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO BE IN
A POSITION WHERE WE'RE LOOKING
AT THAT AGAIN.
I THINK YOU WELL I CAN'T COMMENT
TO WHAT THE MINISTRATION WE
PROPOSING OVER THE NEXT TO YOU
KNOW BUDGET.
CYCLES I THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT
THIS CONVERSATIONS NOT GOING
AWAY -- THIS ISSUES NOT REALLY
GOING AWAY AND SO WE'RE
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO CONTINUE TO
BE.
TALKING ABOUT LOOKING AT A
TRACKING IT IS THE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT STUFF IS DEVELOPING
COMES OUT THAT'S GOING TO BE AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO US IN FIGURING
OUT WHERE TO INVEST.
THIS PROPOSAL WAS REALLY ABOUT
TRYING TO SAY WITHIN THAT
FRAMEWORK OF MAINTAINING BUDGET
RESILIENCY WHAT KIND OF A
COLLECTION OF INVESTMENTS WE CAN
MAKE IN SOME NEEDED AREAS AND SO.
ALL THAT AVIATION WAS IMPORTANT
WE FELT THAT INVESTING IN THE
HEALTH AND WELLNESS OF THE OF
THE FIREFIGHTERS.
WE'RE THE VERY IMPORTANT ENGINES
IS ALWAYS VERY IMPORTANT STEP.
THERE'S JUST A WHOLE LOT OF
AREAS WHERE THIS IS SUPER
CRITICAL AND TRYING TO KEEP
WITHIN THAT FRAMEWORK RESILIENCY.
WE TRY TO DO A BALLOT -- AND
THAT WAS REALLY A FRAMEWORK AND
I AGAIN LIKE I SAID I I DON'T
EXPECT THAT OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS THIS CONVERSATION IS GOING
ANYWHERE WORK AND HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT IT IN HERE
TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP
ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
AND I WOULD JUST I WOULD JUST
ASK IS AS CAL FIRE GOES THROUGH
ITS TEACHING THREE THINKING TO
MAKE IT INTEGRATIVE.
THINK ABOUT HOW TO UTILIZE THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
TO LEAN ON THE RESOURCES AGENCY
RIGHT TO LOOK AT SORT OF OTHER
AGENCIES WITH.
THE SORT OF BROADER STAKE IN.
AND NOT JUST THE BUDGET
RESILIENCY BUT THE ACTUAL
PHYSICAL CLIMATE RESILIENCY THE
STATE AND TRY TO GET SOME
STRATEGIC THINKING BECAUSE WE
MAY ACCEPT TO THINK OF NEW IDEAS
THAT WE DON'T REALLY HAVE AT OUR
DISPOSAL HERE TODAY -- TO IF I
COULD JUST BILLING OF THAT
THOUGHT AGAIN ANY WE TALKED
YESTERDAY ABOUT THE INNOVATIVE
PROCUREMENTS RENDON THINGS THEY
WERE TRYING TO DO SOME THINGS
WHERE IT'S LIKE LET'S FIND SOME
NEW IDEAS I THINK CERTAINLY.
TYING IN ADDITIONAL DEPARTMENTS
AND EXPERTISE OF THOSE AREAS IS
REALLY A PART OF THAT BUT ALSO
YOU KNOW.
FINALLY SALUTE.
THANK YOU AND I WILL -- I JOIN
THE CHOIR I WILL -- I'VE ASSURE
THE MEMBERS THAT THE INCREASE IN
ADDITIONAL FIRE ENGINES IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE IN THE STRATEGIC
PLANNING FOR CALIFORNICA
TOMAHAWKS AND IS C. ONE THIRTIES
AND THAT.
I WILL BE MEETING WITH --
DIRECTOR PORTER AFTER WE GET
THROUGH THIS BUDGET TO TO FIND
OUT WHAT THE WHAT THE NEXT THREE
YEAR PLAN IS FROM CAL FIRE ON
PROVIDING THESE SAID.
THE NECESSARY ADDITIONAL -- FIRE
ENGINE SAID SEND REQUIRE HAS SO
ELOQUENTLY TALKED ABOUT.
WITH THAT.
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
AND TO BE RETURNED FOR THAT THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION.
SEVEN UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI.
GAINES [inaudible]
PLAN [inaudible]
MONEY.
OKAY LET'S MOVE -- TO OUR
DISCUSSION ISSUES ISSUE NUMBER
SIXTEEN GREENHOUSE GASES --
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED.
A SHE WEARS MY SHEET -- THAT.
IS A REVISED GREENHOUSE GAS --
MATTER FOR EXPENDITURE.
AS I INDICATED EARLIER WE EXPECT
THE OPTION TO INCREASE
[inaudible]
THE TIME.
SALES I'M I AM.
AMENDING THE SENATE.
OUR PROPOSAL ON CAP AND TRADE --
AS EXPLAINED IN ITEM OR PAGES.
THIRTY ONE OR THIRTY AND THIRTY
ONE THERE IS SOME.
SEVERAL A I REQUEST THE
BACKFIELD -- THE STATE
RESPONSIBLE AREA WITH -- SEVEN
ITEMS WE'RE GOING TO DELETE THAT
PORTION AND HAVE THE BACKFIELD
OF THE STATE RESPONSIBLE -- AREA
JUST GO FORWARD AS IT WAS AND IN
THOSE NUMBERS THAT YOU SEE.
ON PAGE THIRTY ONE THE TEN
MILLION FOR OF WORK -- WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT THE TWO MILLION FOUR
FIRE OUT REACH AN EXTENSION.
SKIP THE NEXT TO THE TWELVE
MILLION FOR BLOCK GRANTS THE
FIVE MILLION -- FOR STATEWIDE --
CAPABILITY FOR OVERHEAD FIXED
WING AND SATELLITE REMOTE AND
FIVE MILLION.
FOUR MAIN REIMBURSING THE
COUNTIES THOSE MEASURES WILL BE
CUT IN HALF.
THE THE WHICH IS SEVENTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THE THREE MILLION OVER THREE
YEARS TO REIMBURSE THE COUNTIES
TO TRAIN LOCAL PLANNERS AND THE
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION --
ONE TIME REQUIRED FOR OPR WILL
REMAIN INTACT WHICH IS.
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE FIVE
MILLION IN.
LOW WEATHERIZATION COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT WILL BE
REDUCE FROM FORTY MILLION. TO
TWENTY TWO POINT.
FOUR FIVE IF.
MY MATH IS CORRECT.
THAT WILL DO IT.
AND WITH THAT.
WE ARE PLEASE.
THE OPEN OUR HEARING ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU CHAIR CATHY THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE I'M
I'M K<c.cyan> GORDON I'M THE</c>
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH AS WELL AS
THE GOVERNOR'S SENIOR ADVISER ON
CLIMATE CHANGE AND GOING TO GIVE
A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW.
OF THE PRIORITIES IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ON I'M
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FIND I
SHOULD SAY AND I APOLOGIZE TO
THE OUTSIDE I HAVE TO ACTUALLY
LEAVE IN TEN MINUTES SO I'M
GONNA DO THAT OVERVIEW MATT ALL
ME FROM FINANCE WILL TAKE OVER
WITH.
QUESTIONS THERE ARE ALSO PEOPLE
HERE FROM -- MANY OF THE
AFFECTED AGENCIES WHO ARE ABLE
TO GIVE IN YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL
DETAIL SO.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY THAT'S
ALL RIGHT I'M GLAD I COULD STAY --
TO TO GIVE THE HIGH LEVEL
PRESENTATION.
I'M JUST A COUPLE OF OF FRAMING
REMARKS BEFORE GETTING INTO THE
MEAT OF THE BUDGET THE STATE AS
YOU ALL KNOW AND YOU'VE ALL BEEN
A KEY PART OF THE US HAS MADE
MAJOR PROGRESS ON GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION OVER THE PAST DECADE.
GILLOOLY IN THE ELECTRICITY
SECTOR WE'VE MATTER GOALS AHEAD
OF TIME IT'S BEEN YOU KNOW THE
ENVY OF MANY STATES AND
COUNTRIES.
HOWEVER WE ARE STILL SEEING
CHALLENGES IN SOME KEY AREAS
WERE EMISSIONS ARE EITHER STEADY
OR GOING UP.
YEAR BY YEAR THE TICKET LE LY AS
WE SIGNED THE SB ONE FIFTY
REPORT LAST YEAR FROM AIR BE
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS
CONTINUE TO RISE TRANSPORTATION.
COUNTING WE'RE I'D COUNTING --
REFINING EXTRACTING REFINING IS
51% OF OUR MISSION PICTURE AND
PARTICULARLY IN THE AREA OF
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES AND VMT
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED.
THOSE NUMBERS KEEP GOING UP
WE'RE ALSO SEEING.
STEADY STATE BUT GOING UP ON THE
TRANSPORTATION SIDE OF BOTH
INDUSTRIAL AND AGRICULTURAL
SECTORS.
AND OF COURSE INCREASE EMISSIONS
FROM WILDFIRES.
AT THE SAME TIME THE
LEGISLATURE'S RIGHTLY FOCUSED IN
TIME IS LOOKING AT THESE ISSUES
ON THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AND UNDERSERVED AND DON'T
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND WE
KNOW THROUGH.
MANY OF THE BILLS PASSED IN LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT I'M REALLY WITH A FOCUS ON
EQUITY AND WORK FOR SOME
PARTICULAR.
S SIX SEVENTEEN WITHIN I COULD
EQUITY FOCUS AND OF COURSE SB
NINE A ONE ON FIRES HOW
IMPORTANT THOSE -- THOSE OUT
LEGISLATIVE PUSHES HAVE BEEN.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOCUSES IN
ON THESE TWO THINGS ESSENTIALLY
THE AREAS WHERE WE HAVE MADE
LESS PROGRESS.
ON GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTION AND WHERE SHE SHE
POLLUTION IMPACTS MOST DIRECTLY
AFFECT UNDERSERVED AND
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
HE PRIORITY AND IF PARTICULARLY
AND THE INCREASES IN THE MAYOR
VISION.
WAS TO MAKE INVESTMENTS THAT
WOULD AFFECT INDIVIDUALS AND
COMMUNITIES DIRECTLY.
AND REALLY GET AT THAT
INTERSECTION OF CLIMATE IMPACTS
IN PEOPLE'S LIVES YOU'LL ALSO
SEE PARTICULARLY IN THE MAYOR
VISION OF FOCUS ON THE LONGER
TERM HOW DO WE THINK ABOUT THIS
TRANSITION THAT WE'RE COMMITTED
TO MAKE. TO CARBON NEUTRAL
ECONOMY BUT TWENTY FORTY FIVE I
SHOULD SAY AND I'M NEW TO THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT I'VE BEEN
REALLY IMPRESSED BY THE
COLLABORATIVE.
NATURE OF THE DISCUSSIONS
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN
THE AGENCIES SO THIS BUDGET DOES
REFLECT A COLLABORATION ACROSS.
AFFECTED AGENCIES. TWENTY GOING
TO THE LINE ITEMS HERE -- ON THE
BUDGET AND OF COURSE I KNOW
YOU'LL HAVE QUESTIONS BUT I'LL
GIVE IT A HIGH LEVEL TAKE.
I'M YOU SAW OF COURSE IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET -- AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THOSE COMBINED
BUDGETS NOT JUST MAY AND IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET ON A MAJOR FOCUS
ON FOREST MANAGEMENT AND FIRE OF
COURSE I'M COMING OUT OF NINE A
ONE BUT ALSO JUST COMING OUT OF
THE WORST FIRE SEASON THAT WE
SEE IN.
EVER IN CALIFORNIA IN RECORDED
HISTORY.
THOSE INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
CONTINUED IN THE MAY REVISED IN
FIRE.
PARTICULARLY ON PREVENTION AND
RESILIENCE ARE REALLY CRITICAL
THOSE ARE INVESTMENTS IN BOTH
MITIGATION FIRES AGAIN OR WHEN A
BIG CONTRIBUTOR TO GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS IN THE STATE.
BUT ALSO IN CLIMATE RESILIENCE
WE KNOW THAT THE FIRES WILL
BECOME MORE SEVERE AND MORE
FREQUENT GOING FORWARD.
AND THESE INVESTMENTS WE SEE AS
A KEY PART OF A LARGER
RESILIENCE STRATEGY.
YOU'LL ALSO SEE.
I'M IN I BE IN THE JANUARY
BUDGET AND OF COURSE CONTINUE
THROUGH ON TWO MAY I THIS
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN THE
SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM THAT'S
REALLY DIRECT INVESTMENT IN.
IN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER THING
THAT GOES THROUGH THESE
INVESTMENTS.
THE MAJOR AREAS INCREASES IN MAY
ON THAT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT ARE
AS FOLLOWS. ONE IS A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN THE TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
BRINGING THE OVERALL PROGRAM TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO MILLION WHICH
IS NEAR IT NOT QUITE AT BUT NEAR
WHAT THE PROGRAM WAS IN ITS
FIRST YEAR OF OPERATION.
THE REASON THAT WE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOCUSED IN ON
THIS PROGRAM IS THAT IT'S IN
SOME WAYS IT'S A MICROCOSM THAT
BRINGS OGETHER ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS THAT WE ALL
TALK ABOUT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
CLIMATE MITIGATION AND
RESILIENCE IT'S A A PROGRAM THAT
IS DONE AFTER COMMUNITY.
SCALE THAT BRINGS TOGETHER KEY
PRIORITIES OF FOCUS ON
INTEGRATING HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION GREEN SPACES AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCE.
IN UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WITH
A BOTTOM UP APPROACH SO WE HEARD
IN THE AIR BE IN A LISTENING
TOUR LAST YEAR.
ON AYE PRIORITIES ACROSS THE
STATE FOR THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FIND HEARD OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THAT PEOPLE WANTED
COMMUNITY SCALE PROJECTS THEY
WANTED TO DECIDE.
WHAT MAKES THE MOST SENSE FOR
THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES THIS
PROGRAM DOES NOT IT'S A VERY
COMMUNITY SCALP PROGRAM?
WITH A SPECIFIC FOCUS.
ACROSS THE PROJECT.
IN ON EVERYONE OF THE PROJECT
HAS HOUSING TRANSPORTATION AND
OR GREEN SPACES -- INVOLVED IN
THERE'S A SPECIFIC FOCUSING
REDUCING THIS VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED NUMBER THROUGH PROJECTS
AND INCORPORATE MOBILITY OPTIONS
INCLUDING WALKING BIKING AND
TRANSIT.
THAT IS CRITICAL AS A
DEMONSTRATION OF HOW YOU CAN DO
THAT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND WE
THINK VERY CLOSELY RELATED TO
THE LARGER HOUSING AGENDA THAT
THE STATE HAS HOW DO WE BUILD
HOUSING.
MORE SUSTAINABLY HOW DO WE DO
KIND OF GROSS LOOKING FORWARD.
TO TWENTY FIFTY ANOTHER BIG AREA
OF INCREASE ON IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IS ON IS REALLY GETS TO
THIS EQUITY ISSUE BUT ALSO THE
TRANSPORTATION POINT I MADE
EARLIER IN A MEASURE.
ON ON EMISSIONS WHICH IS
DECREASING AIR POLLUTION AND V.
AND EMISSIONS FROM FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR WITH THE
FOCUS ON TRANSPORTATION IN THE
INDUSTRIAL AGRICULTURAL SECTORS.
SO HERE WE HAVE THREE MAJOR
INCREASES ON ONE HI YOU WERE ALL
OF WHICH ARE AIMED AT HELPING
TRANSITION VEHICLES TO BE
CLEANER AND LESS POLLUTING. ONE
MAJOR ONE IS FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE AFTER THE CLEAN
TRUCKS BUSES AND OFFERED VEHICLE
PROGRAM THAT GOES DIRECTLY TO
THIS CONVERSATION WE HAVE IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE IN PARTICULAR.
AND CENTRAL VALLEY AROUND
FREIGHT EMISSIONS.
SECOND IS A SIXTY FIVE MILLION
INCREASE IN ENGINE UPGRADES
REPLACEMENT FOR AGRICULTURAL
VEHICLES THAT'S RIGHT AT THAT
INTERSECTION OF AGRICULTURE
TRANSPORTATION AND INDUSTRY.
IN AN AREA OF THE STATE WERE
POLLUTION STAYS IN THE AIR IN
LOCAL AREAS FOR MUCH LONGER AND
IN MANY OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE.
AND FINALLY FIFTEEN MILLION
INCREASE IN THE ENHANCE FLEET
MODERNIZATION PROGRAM WHICH I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE IS
THAT THE VEHICLE RETIREMENT AND
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM SO THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE OF OUR
LARGER. ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
STRATEGY.
THERE ARE TWENTY SIX MILLION
CARS ON THE ROAD IN CALIFORNIA
TWO MILLION OF THEM ARE OVER
TWENTY YEARS OLD.
THOSE ARE MAJOR CONTRIBUTORS TO
OUR SMOG BROUGHT THE STATE
PEOPLE WITH THOSE VEHICLES ARE
NOT HIGH INCOME PEOPLE THERE IS
A NEED FOR PROGRAMS THAT HELP
PEOPLE TRANSITION FROM.
THOSE TYPES OF VEHICLES TO NEWER
VEHICLES THAT ARE MUCH MORE
EFFICIENT THE PROGRAM GIVES
INCREASED INCENTIVES FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND REALLY
GETS US ON THAT ROAD TOWARD.
YOUR REMISSION IT ALSO GIVES I
SHOULD SAY INCREASE INCENTIVES
FOR LOW INCOME CONSUMERS.
AND A INCENTIVE FOR NOT BUYING
A NEW VEHICLE AT ALL PURCHASE
DISCREPANCY.
THE THIRD ON AREA OF INCREASE ON
THE ON THE LINE ITEMS IS IN THE
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR THIS AS YOU
KNOW IS A CRITICAL SECTOR TO
CALIFORNIA FIFTY MILLION FIFTY
BILLION SKEWS ME A YEAR TO THE
ECONOMY.
THE FOCUS HERE AGAIN IS ON
PROGRAMS IN THIS CRITICAL AREA
WHERE WE'RE SEEING.
KIND OF STEADY STATE ON
EMISSIONS WITH SOME REALLY
IMPORTANT DECREASES BUT ALSO
JUST INCREASES ON THE DIESEL
SIDE AS I SAID AN INCREASE IN
THAT AGRICULTURAL DIESEL PROGRAM
BUT ALSO. TO INCREASES THAT ARE
REALLY GET AT THE HEART OF
WHAT'S GOOD FOR THE SECTOR AND
FOR OUR CLMATE ONE OF THOSE IS --
INCREASE IN IN A FUNDING FOR
HEALTHY SOILS WHICH IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF HOW WE THINK
ABOUT THIS LONG TERM QUESTION OF
HOW DO WE ACTUALLY.
REMOVE CARPET FROM THE ERROR AS
WELL AS A STOPPING THE ADMITTING
AS MUCH OF IT -- ALSO AT TEN
MILLION INCREASE IN THE METHANE
REDUCTION PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION TO THESE SPECIFIC
ITEMS WHICH ARE ALL INCREASES IN
SPECIFIC AGENCY BUDGETS THERE
ARE TWO AREAS -- I'VE INCREASE
THAT OUR PRIORITIES FOR THE
GOVERNOR AND AND YOU SEE THESE
THOUGHT ONE OF THESE IN BOTH AND
BOTH JANUARY IN MAY AND ONE IS
IN ADDITION IN MAY.
THE FIRST IS A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN PROVIDING WORKFORCE
TRAINING AND HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS TO HELP IDENTIFY
AND SUPPORT.
HIGH QUALITY JOBS ACROSS EVERY
OTHER AREA OF GREENHOUSE GAS
FINING INVESTMENT.
THAT WILL BE NECESSARY TO GET TO
THESE EMISSIONS WE KNOW FROM
RESEARCH THAT'S BEEN DONE IN MY
COLLEAGUE TIM RAINY FROM THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD IS
HERE TO ANSWER I'M SURE WHAT
WILL BE QUESTIONS ON THIS
PROGRAM.
WE KNOW FROM WORK THAT THE BOARD
AND OTHERS HAVE DONE THAT THE
MAJORITY OF JOBS CREATED BY THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FINDER
IN CONSTRUCTION.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
CONSTRUCTION SECTOR SUFFERS FROM
A LACK OF QUALIFIED WORKERS TO
DO GREEN BUILDINGS BUILDING
UPGRADES INC AND OPERATING MADE.
OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE IN
HIGH QUALITY HIGH QUALITY GREEN
BUILDINGS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT WHERE PEOPLE
WE SEE A LOSS OF EMISSIONS.
GAINES IT WHEN YOU PUT MONEY
INTO EFFICIENCY IT'S ALL WELL
AND GOOD IF YOU DON'T ADEQUATELY
MAINTAIN THOSE PROJECTS YOU LOSE
THE GAMES.
SO WE ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT.
THE WORK FORCE OF THE CARBON
NEUTRAL ECONOMY IS A CRITICAL
PIECE OF ACHIEVING THAT ECONOMY.
YOU'LL SEE IN THE BUDGET IN
INCREASED SPECIFICALLY AND MAY
OR AREAS OF THE STATE WHERE WE
NEED TO SEE A DIVERSIFICATION
AWAY FROM AYE AYE VERY HEAVY JOB
BASED IN THE FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY SO WE CALLED UP KERN
COUNTY.
ON BECAUSE IT'S THE NUMBER ONE
BY FAR AN OIL AND GAS ON IN THE
STATE.
AND COUNTY IS ALREADY SEEING A
DECLINE IN OIL AND GAS JOBS
BECAUSE OF AUTOMATION.
ALSO SEEING A DECLINE BECAUSE OF
OTHER STATES HAVING A RAMP UP
I'M PARTICULARLY GAS.
AND ARE I'D CLIMATE POLICIES
OVER THE LONG TERM AS WELL AS
OTHER COUNTRIES AND STATES
CLIMATE POLICIES HAVE BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED BY THE OIL AND GAS
SECTOR AS SOMETHING THAT WILL
AFFECT THE INDUSTRY.
SO WE PUT AN ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THERE FOR A TRANSITION STRATEGY
IN THOSE AREAS OF THE STATES
WHERE THERE'S HEAVY DEPENDENCE
ON ONE INDUSTRY -- THAT IS A
HIGH CARBON INDUSTRY
[inaudible]
IN ADDITION.
YOU'LL SEE A NEW OF FOCUS IN THE
MAPLE REVISE FOR ANOTHER PIECE
OF THE PUZZLE ON HOW DO WE GET
THERE HOW TO GET TO CARBON
NEUTRAL.
I'M AND THAT'S AT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION A NEW -- ALLOCATION FOR
A STUDY THAT WILL PROVIDE A
ROADMAP OF HOW TO KERR
TRANSITION TO A CARBON NEUTRAL
ECONOMY BY TWENTY FIFTY WITH A
FOCUS WHICH IS UNUSUAL FOR THE
IS.
ON BOTH THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
THE ECONOMIC FACTORS AND YOU'LL
SEE THAT WE'VE RECOMMENDED THAT
THE AGENCIES ACROSS THE BOARD
INCLUDING LABOR BE PART OF
SCOPING OUT THIS STUDY.
THE FOCUS WILL BE ON
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING OUR
FOSSIL FUEL DEMAND IN THE STATE
TO REACH THAT CARBON NEUTRALITY
GOAL BUT ALSO WILL CONSIDER HOW
THE STATE WILL MANAGE THAT
DECLINE IN FOSSIL FUEL.
SUPPLY THAT DECLINE FOSSIL FUEL
JOBS AND THE ECONOMIC IMPACT.
ON SOME OF WHICH IS AS THAT IS
ALREADY HAPPENING THROUGH
AUTOMATION AND MARKET FORCES BUT
WILL LIKELY BE ACCELERATED BY
THE TYPES OF POLICIES.
NOT ONLY CALIFORNIA BUT OTHER
STATES AND COUNTRIES ARE PUTTING
IN PLACE.
SO THAT IS THE HIGH LEVEL.
ANA THE GOVERNOR'S ON PROPOSED
BUDGET AND I KNOW YOU WILL HAVE
MANY QUESTIONS I REALLY WISH I
COULD BE HERE TO ANSWER THEM BUT
MY VENERABLE COLLEAGUES WHO WILL
BE HERE MENTAL ME FROM FINANCE
WILL BE HERE AND I KNOW THEIR
PEOPLE AND AND THE ROOM FROM ALL
OF THESE.
AGENCIES SO I WILL.
TURNING TO THEM THEY'RE MUCH
SMARTER THAN ME IN ANY CASE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
LA -- DO YOU HAVE COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ROSS
BROWN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OF FOCUS MOST
OF MY COMMENTS ON KIND OF THE
BROADER FRAMEWORK REVENUE
PROJECTIONS AND KINDA YOU KNOW
THE NEW MONEY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROJECT IN
WOULD BE AVAILABLE -- ON THE
SPENDING SIDE AS WE SAID BEFORE
I MEAN A LOT I THINK A LOT OF
THE MAJOR DECISIONS ARE AROUND.
JUST DIFFERENT PRIORITIES -- YOU
KNOW HOW THE LEGISLATURE
PRIORITY PRIORITISE IS A LOT OF
THE IFFERENT BENEFITS THAT
COULD BE ACHIEVED THROUGH THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS WHETHER THEY
BE -- POLLUTION -- ADAPTATION --
RESEARCH THOSE ARE ALL ALL KIND
OF WERE THE GOALS AND NOBODY'S
PROGRAMS CAN ACHIEVE THOSE
THINGS IT'S A LARGE THE AMERICAN
HOW TO PRIORITIZE THOSE THINGS.
ON THE OVERALL FRAMEWORK IN THE
REVENUE I JUST SOME HIGH LEVEL
NUMBERS HERE THE ADMINISTRATION
RELATIVE TO THE JANUARY PROPOSAL
IS PROJECTING ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS MORE AN AUCTION REVENUE
OVER THE CURRENT YEAR IN THE
BUDGET YEAR.
AND SO SINCE 60% OF THAT IS
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED THAT
LEAVES ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS MORE FOR
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING AND THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
ALLOCATE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION OF THAT THREE HUNDRED
MILLION.
IN GENERAL WE ARE REVENUE
ESTIMATES ARE VERY CLOSE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PARTICULARLY IN
THE BUDGET YEAR -- AND THE
PRIMARY DIFFERENCE I THINK
BETWEEN OUR ESTIMATES AND
THERE'S ARE IN THE CURRENT YEAR --
FOR THE AUCTION THAT JUST
OCCURRED YESTERDAY.
BASED ON KIND OF CURRENT MARKET
CONDITIONS WERE PROJECT IN --
REVENUE WOULD BE ROUGHLY --
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
HIGHER THAN THE ADMINISTRATION
IS ASSUMING AND THAT'S ESTIMATES
AND SO THAT LEAVES AGAIN WITH
TAKING A CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS OFF ABOUT SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS MORE.
FOR DISCRETIONARY SPENDING IN
THE CURRENT YEAR OR AND SHE'S IN
THE BUDGET OR IN FUTURE YEARS.
THERE'S A YOUNG AS WE TALKED
ABOUT.
MANY TIMES BEFORE THERE'S A LOT
OF UNCERTAINTY AROUND KIND OF
WHAT REVENUE IS GOING TO BE --
ANDS FOR THE MAY AUCTION THE ONE
THAT I JUST MENTIONED TO RESULTS
FROM THAT OPTION ARE EXPECTED TO
BE AVAILABLE NEXT.
WEDNESDAY -- AND SO WHEN WE GET
THAT INFORMATION WHEN IT'S
AVAILABLE WE'LL UPDATE THE
LEGISLATURE WITH WITH UPDATED
REVENUE ESTIMATES.
OKAY -- WE HAVE A CONTINUING
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE USE OF
FUNDS IN THE NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET -- FOR PROJECTS.
WHERE THE PROJECTS THAT MIGHT
NOT OF MEAT IS STRICT NEXUS
THAT'S REQUIRED UNDER A. B.?
THIRTY TWO IS IT STILL YOUR
OPINION THAT THE FUNDING
PROPOSAL WOULD -- IN NINETEEN
TWENTY SHOULD IT HERE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS OF AB THIRTY TWO
BECAUSE MUCH OF THIS MUCH SOME
OF THE PROJECT I OBJECTS AND
I'VE COMMENTED.
PUBLICLY ABOUT THE BEING STINGY
ABOUT.
A HEARING TO THE RULE OF LAW
THAT WERE THAT WERE BOUND TO IN
THE NINETEEN TWENTY FISCAL YEAR.
I MEAN I I THINK IT'S IT'S A
LEGAL QUESTION WHERE THERE IS
SOME UNCERTAINTY AROUND KIND OF
WHAT IT IS YOU KNOW WHAT KIND OF
THE RESTRICTIONS ARE ON THE
FUNDS NOW I KNOW.
LET'S COUNCIL IS GONNA HAS
WEIGHED IN ON THIS AND AND
THINKS THAT THE FUNDS NEED TO BE
SPENT ON ON A. B. THIRTY TWO
RATED ACTIVITIES AND GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS I THINK.
WITH THAT SAID THERE STILL.
A BIT OF UNCERTAINTY -- SO I I
THINK IN THE END OUR ADVICE TO
YOU I THINK IT'S JUST KIND OF
YOU KNOW TAKING THAT RISK INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN KIND OF
MAKING THOSE ALLOCATIONS I DON'T
THINK THERE'S SORT OF A A CLEAR
ANSWER ON WHAT EXACTLY THE
RESTRICTIONS ARE BUT I THINK
THERE IS.
SOME.
SOME LEGAL RISK ASSOCIATED WITH
SPENDING THE MONEY ON ACTIVITIES
THAT DON'T DIRECTLY REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
VERY GOOD ALRIGHT LET'S OPEN THE
PUBLIC HEARING I'M SURE WE HAVE
A MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC -- THAT
WOULD LIKE -- TO COMMENT ON
ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN ACHIEVING
CARBON NEUTRAL ECONOMY BUT THE
CAP AND TRADE THE MAY REVISE.
WE HAVE THE SENATE VERSION WE
HAVE THE GOVERNOR'S VERSION.
AND I'M SURE SEVEN THREE OVER
THE ASSEMBLY HAS THEIR OWN
VERSION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I
GUESS I GET TO GO FIRST NOT
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION.
AND SOME OF OUR MEMBER AGENCIES --
WHILE WE THINK THERE COULD
ALWAYS BE MORE FUNDING DIRECTED
TO THE HEAVY DUTY PROGRAMS WE DO
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION -- WHICH WOULD INCREASE
THE JANUARY AMOUNT BY FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS -- THAT BUSES
CLEAN BUSES HAVE ACCESS TO I
THINK IS IT'S NOT LOST ON THIS
BODY WE ARE NOW UNDER A
REGULATORY MANDATE BY THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IS TO START
ELECTRIC ELECTRIFYING OUR FLEETS --
IN THE COMING YEARS AND SO THIS
FUNDING HELPS AGENCIES GET AN
EARLY START ON THAT.
ON THAT PROGRESS THANK YOU AND
THE REVISED MANAGER BEFORE US
REFLECTS THE HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
DOLLARS.
I CAN MORNING CLASS OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE HERE
TO SUPPORT THE FUNDING FOR CAL
OR CYCLE AS WELL AS THE HEALTHY
CELLS FUNDING.
AT THE COUNTER CYCLE FUNDING WAS
CUT TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
SINCE THIS MORNING -- I I THINK
THIS COMMITTEE IS AWARE OF THE
BENEFITS OF OF THAT PROGRAM --
BOTH FROM A GREENHOUSE GAS COT
EFFECTIVENESS PERSPECTIVE BUT
ALSO.
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE HOW IT
HELPS OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE THE
HEALTHY SOULS PROGRAM THE FOOD
RECOVERY AND FOOD BANK
INFRASTRUCTURE ETCETERA -- WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT THE PROGRAMS AND THE
FORD WORKING WITH THE THANK YOU
THANK NEXT.
THE COLONEL WENT ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES -- JUST WANT TO SUPPORT.
THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION -- FOR ORGANIC WASTE
DIVERSION AND RECYCLING OF
STRUCTURE.
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE IN THE
UPCOMING IMPLEMENTATION THOSE
REGULATIONS -- RESPECTING THAT'S
COST ABOUT THREE BILLION IN
CAPITAL INVESTMENTS TO GET THE
REQUIRED FACILITIES NEEDED TO
MEET THOSE GOALS -- AND SO THIS
IS A GOOD FIRST STEP AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT -- IN ADDITION
WERE ALSO VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
TCC ALLOCATION OF FIFTY SEVEN
MILLION AS WE HEARD TODAY AS
WELL THAT'S GREAT PROGRAM FOR
COUNTIES AND DEFINITELY SUPPORT
AS WELL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OR THREE COMMA STRAIGHTEN OUT OF
WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND --
I LIKE TO FIRST THANK THE SENATE
FOR THE REVISION THAT YOU
PROPOSED.
THAT RESTORES FUNDING TO OUR
BRING GREENING RICH FORESTRY
WETLANDS AN ADAPTATION OF
RESILIENCY PROGRAMS.
I I THINK IN MY YOU KNOW NOT
JUST MY OPINION THERE'S JUST
NOTHING THE STATE CAN DO THAT'S
MORE IMPORTANT THAN PREPARING
OUR COMMUNITIES FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND THERE IS NOW A LANDSCAPE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S PREPARED FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES ARE RIGHT
FOR FLOODING AND HEAT THAT
HASN'T.
HAPPENED TO THE EXTENT THAT IT
WILL.
BUT WE'VE SEEN WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE FOREST -- WITH THESE
WILDFIRES BECAUSE WE WEREN'T
PREPARED -- FOR YOU KNOW WHAT WE
KNEW WAS COMING DR DROUGHT --
MORE EXPOSURE TO THE THE RISK OF
WILDFIRE THE SAME THING HAPPENS
IN OUR URBAN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES -- IN A WHILE
TORNADOES AND HURRICANES GET ALL
THE HEADLINES IT'S HEATING
FLOODING THAT KILLED MORE PEOPLE
IN THE U. S. THAN ANY OTHER
WEATHER RELATED EVENT.
AND THE URBAN FORESTRY IN A ROOM --
GREEN PROGRAMS ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THEY ARE MEDICAID OR
IS BUT THEY ALSO HELPED OUT
THESE -- COMMUNITIES OBVIOUSLY
WETLANDS ARM ARE MEDICARE'S AS
WELL AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITMENT TO THE CONSERVANCY'S
AND W. C. B.. FOR RESILIENCY
THESE ARE REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT INTERVENTIONS THAT WE
CAN'T WAIT TO DO I MEAN IT'S SO
AGAIN I THINK IT'S A MATTER OF
LIFE AND DEATH.
AND IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN SO WE
SHOULD BE MAKING THESE
INVESTMENTS NOW I SHE WAS THE IF
DONE WITH THE REVISION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. ONE OF THEM YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT AUTUMN ON CALIFORNIA
ALSO -- IN SUPPORT OF THE
REVISIONS ON RELATED TO NATURAL
WORKING LANDS WETLANDS COASTAL
ADAPTATION.
W. C. B. -- OTHERS -- HEALTHY
SOILS.
THIS IS THE ONLY SECTOR THAT
WILL ONLY -- THAT SEQUESTERS
CARBON -- ALSO -- NOT JUST
QUAESTORS AT SO WE ARE.
INCREDIBLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROVISIONS THANK YOU.
AND ONLY SERVER -- DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND I WOULD LIKE TO
LINE OURSELVES OF THE COMMENTS
MADE FOR BY TRUST FOR PUBLIC
LAND IN AUDUBON -- AND REALLY
SUPPORT THE THE BUDGET
ESPECIALLY IN REGARDS TO NATURAL
WORKING LANDS AND WETLANDS
PROGRAMS KICK YOU.
ALL RIGHT TO FROM CALIFORNIA
RELIEF WE STRONGLY APPRECIATE
THE SENATE LEADERSHIP AND
RESTORING FUNDING FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES THESE INVESTMENTS IN.
URBAN FORESTRY AND IRVING GREEN
ARE A PRIORITY FOR ASSISTING
WITH COMMITTEES FOR ALL -- AND
WILL GO TOWARDS CRITICAL GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE -- TO HELP REDUCE
JEEZ JEEZ -- FOR IT TO MEET OUR
TWENTY THIRTY GOALS AND CARBON
NEUTRALITY THANK YOU.
STRUCTURE MEMBERS BRENDAN TO A
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION THAT'S EXECUTIVE
OFFICERS FROM ALL THIRTY FIVE
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS AS YOU KNOW.
WE ARE AT A DEEPLY CONCERNED
WITH A DRAMATIC REDUCTION IN AB
SIX SEVENTEEN INCENTIVE FUNDING --
THAT TO BE THE CASE WITH THE
WITH THE SENATE PLAN.
AND WE KNOW THERE ARE OVER
BURDENED COMMUNITIES -- WAITING
TO GET THOSE REDUCTIONS AND NOW
WE CAN GET THAT MONEY OUT FAST
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO GET THOSE.
AND REAL.
QUANTIFIABLE PERMANENT
REDUCTIONS AND SO WE HOPE YOU
RECONSIDER THAT AND I ALSO DID
WANT TO NOTE.
THAT -- IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING
IS AN ISSUE IT APPEARS TO STILL
BE IN THE PLAN IN THE SENATE
PLAN WHICH WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE -- BUT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH.
PURCHASING MONITORING EQUIPMENT
AND DEVELOPING COMMUNITY
REDUCTION PLANS ENGAGING THE
COMMUNITY AND THEN -- YOU KNOW
AND ALSO OF COURSE THE STAFF
THAT GOES ALONG WITH THAT AS
I'VE NOTED IN PREVIOUS TESTIMONY --
AND WE ARE FINDING AS I'VE SAID
AT SAID EARLIER.
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS THAT OUR
COSTS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
THAN THE FIFTY MILLION THAT IS
IN THE BUDGET -- FOR FOR
IMPLEMENTATION SO WANT TO
CONTINUE TO DO A GOOD JOB ON
THAT BUT WE NEED THE RESOURCES
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT AND OF
COURSE WE NEED THE INCENTIVE
DOLLARS AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TOWN ABS WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
ASSOCIATING MY COMMENTS WITH THE
MISTER TO WORK FROM CAP COLOR
NOT JUST NOTE THAT -- THE FIRST
YEAR MAYBE SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITY DESIGNATIONS HAD TAKE
TEN COMMUNITIES THERE'S AN
EXPECTATION THAT WE'LL BE ADDING
COMMUNITIES EVERY YEAR FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AT
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING FOR
MONITORING FOR STAFFING -- FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF THE MISSION
REDUCTION PLANS AND THEN WHEN WE
LOOK AT IT AT INCENTIVE FUNDING
TO ACTUALLY GET THOSE REDUCTIONS
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED.
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
INCREASING THOSE AMOUNTS RATHER
THAN -- DECREASING THEM IN THIS
PROPOSAL THANKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS ROSS
BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF SOUTH COAST
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
WAS OF SAY MY COSTS OF THE
PREVIOUS TWO SPEAKERS FROM PEPCO
AND BAY AREA.
ABOUT THE NEED FOR INCREASED
FUNDING FOR THE EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTY PROGRAM ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND THE SCENT OF
SIDE.
GOOD MORNING JOHN KENNEDY --
WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE RETENTION OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR HEALTHY FORCE
WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION AND WERE
ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF THE FUNDING
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
ORGANICS WASTE RECYCLING.
WE'VE GOT ABOUT TWO HUNDRED TO
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AND IMPLEMENTATION
COSTS FROM SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE THIS IS A GOOD START --
AND ALSO WANT TO ASSOCIATE THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES WITH
MY COMMENTS ON ORGANIC WASTE
RECYCLING THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TREES A BROKERAGE
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA COMPOST
COLLISION.
I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WAYS AND I
DO WANNA REQUEST AT FIFTY FIFTY
DISTRIBUTION -- METHANE
REDUCTION FOR MANURE MANAGEMENT
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING AFTERNOON MATTEO
CHROME HALF THE MOUNTAINS ARE
CREATION CONSERVATION AUTHORITY
SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE AT
THE FORTY AND SAID I'M
AGRICULTURE IN OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT.
I'M LIKE TO THANK THE SENATE AND
THIS COMMITTEES LEADERSHIP ON
NOT GETTING THE THIS AMOUNT OF
RESILIENCE AND NETWORKING LANDS
FUNDING INTO THE BUDGET -- AND
WE HOPE YOU CONTINUE TO PUSH
INTO THAT THE FINAL VERSION
THANK YOU.
FUTURE MEMBERS NIKITA CROWDED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCILWE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE REDUCTION IN THE
FUNDING FOR THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM SINCE
THIS MORNING.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT AND CRITICAL PROGRAMS
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE SAFE BUT
ALSO AFFORDABLE HOMES ESPECIALLY
ESPECIALLY FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE
HARMONIZING THE BUILDING SECTOR.
IT'S ABOUT ENSURING THAT LOW
INCOME FAMILIES THAT IS YOU KNOW
SPEND A DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE
OF THEIR INCOME ON THEIR ENERGY
BILLS HAVE ACCESS TO RESOURCES --
AND TO THIS PROGRAM THAT HAS
OPEN AMAZING TRACK RECORD OF
PRODUCING BILLS BY ALMOST 30%
AND ENERGY USE BY ALMOST 40% SO
WITH SUPPORT INCREASING THAT AT
LEAST SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS JOSIAH
YOUNG OF FIRST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLES
COALITION GENERALLY IN SUPPORT
OF THE LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
ALLOCATIONS.
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
IN IN SUPPORT OF THE SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION FOR CAL RECYCLE
ORGANICS WASTE DIVERSION.
JUST UNDERSTANDING HOW IMPORTANT
OF A PROMPT PROGRAM THAT IS WE
WOULD ASK THAT IT WOULD BE BACK
AT THE HUNDRED MILLION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON PVC LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY A
COUPLE THINGS -- OR SUPPORT OF
OF THE INCREASE THE TCC WOULD
LIKE TO SEE A LITTLE BIT HIGHER
I THINK -- I REQUEST WAS A
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
CRITICAL FOR INVESTMENTS THAT WE
NEED TO SEE IN LOW INCOME AREAS --
SIX ONE SEVEN I THINK THAT
THERE'S THE FUNDING PEACE BUT WE
REALLY NEED TO SEE THAT THE THE
THE REGULATIONS PIECES WELL TO
REQUIRE EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS IN
AGAIN THE MOST VULNERABLE AREAS --
ON THE ON THE METHANE --
UNDERSTAND THAT IS TO INCREASE
IN TEN MILLION DOLLARS -- ON TO
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FROM
WHAT WE SAW EARLIER TODAY I
BELIEVE AND APPRECIATE THAT IT
IS DIRECTED EXCLUSIVELY TO AMP
IS OUR UNDERSTANDING.
AS WE'VE -- PRIDE BROUGHT TO YOU
BEFORE FIND THE DIGESTIVE
PROGRAM DOES NOTHING TO ADDRESS
THE THE CO BENEFITS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE G. G. R. F. OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
EQUITY AND REALLY DOING THINGS
DIFFERENTLY THE DIGESTIVE
PROGRAM DOES NOTHING TO ADDRESS
MASSIVE -- THE NEWER -- SAID
THAT THE IMPACTS OF MANY OR LAND
APPLIED TO TO TO WATER TO THE
SURFACE WATER AND GROUNDWATER.
THERE'S NOTHING TO ADDRESS THEIR
IMPACTS FROM DAIRIES AND WE'RE
JUST VERY PLEASED TO SEE THE
MOVE IN THIS DIRECTION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO TALKING TO MORE ABOUT
IT THANKS SO MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MORNING ROCKY RESCUED COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR FIRST ONE I THINK
TWENTY FOUR RESTORING THE MONEY
TO THESE SPRING REVISED LEVELS
FOR THE CLEAN BUT A TRUCK BUS.
OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT AND
FORTUNATELY IT STILL FALLS SHORT
WE HAVE A MULTI YEAR PROBLEM.
THE STATE HAS TRIED TO SOLVE IT
WITH THE SINGLE YOUR SOLUTIONS --
WE BELIEVE THAT A MULTI YEAR
COMMITMENT TO THIS PROGRAM IS
REQUIRED TO REDUCE DIESEL
EMISSIONS.
MORE PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA DIE A
PREMATURE DEATHS FROM FREIGHT
RELATED EMISSIONS THAN HOMICIDES
THAT OCCUR IN THE STATE BY A SIG
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE.
SO IT'S AN ISSUE WE REALLY NEED
TO ADDRESS.
TO WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM CAP CO AND
BAY AREA AIR DISTRICT REGARDING --
SIX ONE SEVEN AND THE FUNDING
CUT THEIR IT'S SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION THESE ARE COMMUNITIES.
THAT HAVE BEEN -- DISADVANTAGE
FOR DECADES AND WE WOULD HATE TO
SEE THIS STATE.
TURN IT BACK ON THOSE VERY
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED US THE
MOST THANKS SO MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE S. OVER THERE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WOULD LIKE.
TO EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION FOR
THE INCLUSION OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDS FOR AGRICULTURAL DIESEL
UPGRADES AS WELL THE INCREASE IN
FUNDING FOR THE CLEAN TRUCK AND
BUS.
AND WE WOULD ALSO LIKETO
ENCOURAGE THE USE OF MULTI YEAR
FUNDING TO ENCOURAGE FASTER
ADOPTION OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES
FOR THE FREE INDUSTRY THANK YOU.
MARIN BE NOW WE HAVE THE
INTERNATIONAL LONGSHORE AND
WAREHOUSE UNION.
WE WELCOME THE INCREASE FOR
CLEAN TRUCKS AND OFFROAD FRIGHT
EQUIPMENT -- WE ASK FOR A
SPECIFIC LOCATION FOR WORDS HAS
THAT WE HAVE EMPLOYEES THAT ARE
READY TO CLEAN UP THE PORTS AND
KEEP THE WORKERS EMPLOYED -- BUT
THAT AND SUPPORTER OF THE
INCREASED THANK YOU.
HEY MAN ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA --
MANAGES ALLIANCE WOULD LIKE TO
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL.
OF REGARDING THE ALLOCATION OF A
HUNDRED TO TWO MILLION TO THE
THE TO CC PROGRAM -- AS THAT
WITH AND IN ORDER -- TO
VIRTUALLY TRANSFORM CHANGES TO A
CURRENT ESTATES MOST IS MANAGED
COMMUNITIES -- LARGE SCALE
GRANTS AND LARGE -- PROGRAM
OCCASIONS ARE NEEDED.
ALSO SINCE FOURTEEN TO CITY
PLANNING GRANTS OF ALREADY BEEN --
FUNDED WE NEED HIGHER LOCATION
FOR TCC AT TO MAKE SURE THE
NUMBER OF THOSE PROMISING GRANTS
BECOME REALITY SO THANK YOU AND
WE RECOMMEND ELECT ALLOCATION.
DENNIS ALL THE ON THE ON THE
OTHER THE ALLMAN LANCE
CALIFORNIA GRAIN FEED CALIFORNIA
C. DISSOCIATION A FEW OTHER
AGRICULTURAL ENTITIES.
WE'D LIKE TO FIRST OF ALL
RECOGNIZE THE INCREASE IN AND
APPRECIATE THE INCREASE. FOR THE
OFF ROAD IN AND FARM EQUIPMENT A
PROGRAM OF THE FARMER PROGRAM
HOWEVER -- THE NEED FOR THAT
WELL AS A NINETY MILLION THIS
YEAR THE NEW NEED MILLION
EXCEEDS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION.
AND THAT'S PRESCRIBED NEED AND
THE THE VALUE OF THAT IS YOU GET
G. G. R. F. REDUCTIONS AS WELL
AS CRITERIA.
CONTAMINANT REDUCTIONS AND
ASSIST WITH CLEANER -- ZIP
COMPLIANCE AS WELL.
SO THERE'S DROOL VALUE THERE AND
ALSO LIKE TO ADDRESS ORGANICS
RECYCLING WE APPRECIATE THE
INCREASED -- TO ORGANICS
RECYCLING IN A RECENT REPORT BY --
COVER CYCLE THEY IDENTIFIED
AGRICULTURE AND MANY OF THE USES
HAS THE BIGGEST OPPORTUNITY FOR
ORGANICS RECYCLING -- AND WHERE
THE MAJORITY MATERIAL GOES
HOWEVER.
I CAN RECYCLE POLICY HAS REFUSED
TO FUND TECHNOLOGIES -- THAT ARE
OUTSIDE OF COMPOSTING AND AND
AND OF DIGESTION SO WE WERE ARE
ADVOCATING -- FOR TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL FUNDING FOR THOSE GRANTS
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT IS THAT
COMES OF THAT ISSUE PERCOLATES
THANK YOU.
MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA SOLUTION
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT FIRST I'D LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF CAP CO AND THE
OTHER AIR DISTRICTS IN THE NEED
FOR INCREASED EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN FUNDING.
SECONDLY I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
THE GOVERNOR AND THE SENATE IN
THE PROPOSED PLAN TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR THE FORMER PROGRAM.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ALLOCATED TO THE
PROGRAM AND ITS CRITICAL FOR US
IN TERMS OF CRITERIA.
EMITTING POLLUTION UP.
TERRY POLLUTION REDUCTIONS AS
WELL AS GHG EMISSION REDUCTIONS.
AND IT PROVIDES IMMEDIATE
BENEFITS -- TO THE DISTRICT WE
HAVE TWENTY OF THE THIRTY MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE THE SPENDING IS VERY
IMPORTANT WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SELECT US HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP
AXING COUNCIL STOP WASTE ALWAYS
CESSATION NORTH AMERICA HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE RIVERS CENTER VISION TOWARDS
COLOR CYCLE FUNDING FOR WASTE
DIVERSION.
AND RECYCLING ALSO HERE ON
BEHALF OF CITY OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI.
SAID HE TO EXPRESS FOR ALSO FOR
TOWARDS THE CALIFORNIA RUNNING
COMMUNITY FORESTRY PROGRAM -- AS
CAL FIRE URBAN ME FORCE THE
FUNDS ARE USEFUL FOR CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND OTHER MUSIC IS THE
POLICIES AROUND THE STATE
BECAUSE THEY ALLOW FOR EARLY
TREAT MAINTENANCE.
AMATORY PROGRAMS AND DEVELOPMENT
URBAN FORCED YOU MENTION PLANS.
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE NECESSARY
FOR CITIES TO PROACTIVELY ME
MANAGE THEIR URBAN FOREST.
STORE CARBON SAVE.
ENERGY IN PROTECT PRESENTS FROM
TEMPERATURE RISES THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON HANNAH
GOLDSMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION WE
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION AND
THE COMMITTEE PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE THE FUNDING FOR THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT.
BUT WE WOULD URGE YOU TO WORK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ON WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE NUMBER FOR THAT IS
THERE FACING SOME CHALLENGES
RIGHT NOW WITH ANTICIPATED. TO
RUN OUT OF FUNDS FROM LAST YEAR
AS WELL AS AND LOOKING AT HOW TO
ALTER THE PROGRAM FOR THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR TO FIT WITHIN.
THE CONFINES OF WHAT'S BEEN
PROPOSED SO I URGE YOU TO WORK
WITH THEM REGARDING THAT MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE FUNDING
FOR THAT HIGH BURDEN ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE VOUCHER
INCENTIVE PROGRAM H. MAP -- FOR
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY FUNDING
AND THE PILOTS AND DEMOS THAT
GOES TO THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD --
WE THINK THAT THE FUNDING FOR
THAT IS NOT AS HIGH AS IT NEEDS
TO BE AND IT'S NOT RELIABLE AS
YOU KNOW AND OTHER FOLKS ALSO
ASK FOR THAT BUT BOTH RELIABLE
pAND ADEQUTE FUNDING FOR THAT
PROGRAM ARE STREAMLINED PORTENT
TO REACH OUR CLIMB AN AIR
QUALITY GOALS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THEN THE
COMMISSION WITH A CALIFORNIA
BICYCLE COALITION HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
FOR ALL COALITION A MULTI SECTOR
COALITION THAT AT LOOKS AT A
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND AND
TRANSPORTATION AND THE
INTERSECTIONS HOW TO REDUCE OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BECAUSE
OF THAT.
WE ARE HERE IN APPRECIATION OF
THE ALLOCATIONS TOWARDS IRVINE
GREENING IN URBAN FORESTRY AND
ALSO ECHO COMMENTS MADE ON THE
LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION.
PROGRAM WE APPRECIATE THE
ALLOCATIONS BUT DO YOU KNOW THAT
ALL THREE PROGRAMS DO YOU HAVE --
QUITE A NEED WE ALSO HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL ASK -- UP FOR THAT CD
R. P. PROGRAM -- WE DO SEE A
NEED FOR E. BIKES ELECTRIC BIKES
TO BE INCLUDED AS AN AS AN
OPTION FOR PEOPLE TO RECEIVE.
A AN ABILITY TO ADOPT THAT
TECHNOLOGY IT'S A GREAT WAY TO
GET PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR CARS --
IN ON TO AT A HEALTHY BENEFICIAL
WAY OF OF MOVING AROUND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE PATTERSON
WITH AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST
HERE IN SUPPORT OF YOUR PROPOSAL
FOR THE AGRICULTURAL PROGRAMS
SPECIFIC TO THE CLIMATE SMART
ACT -- PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE -- WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO SEE THOSE NUMBERS
THERE WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
YOU -- TO GET SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING -- SPECIFICALLY FIFTY
MILLION FOR HEALTHY SOILS FORTY
MILLION FOR AMP AND FORTY ALSO
FOR THE SWEET PROGRAMS THERE'S A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD
AND SCALE UP CAPACITY WITH THESE
LANDOWNERS -- TO MEET SOME OF
OUR CLIMATE CHANGE OBJECTIVES
THAT WE HAVE OUT THERE -- TO
DRESS SIGMA AND THE WATER YOU
KNOW -- ISSUES THAT WE WILL HAVE
YOU KNOW IN THIS CHANGING
CLIMATE SO -- A LOT OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IS NEEDED OUT THERE
SOME PREDICTABILITY AND HOW THAT
FUNDING IS OUT LATER -- WILL
HELP IN THAT SCALING UP SO VERY
MUCH APPRECIATIVE OF THE
PROPOSAL TODAY THANK YOU.
BACK IN MARK AS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK CARBON CYCLE
INSTITUTE AN AS A COURTESY TO A
COLLEAGUE TODAY THE CENTER FOR
FOOD POLICY.
WELL WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
INCREASED OF HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM WE BELIEVE THE SENATE'S
PROPOSAL AS A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH FOR CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE CLIMATE SOLUTIONS WE
THINK THE SENATE FOR THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS IN THE
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM.
THE ALTERNATIVE MINIMUM
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM THE STATE
WATER ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAM
AND THE CAL CYCLE ORGANIC WASTE
DIVERSION PROGRAM THANK YOU. ONE
INTERNALLY BECAUSE THE NUMBERS
OF COMMITTEE PAUL MASON WITH
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST.
THANK YOU THIS PROPOSAL COMING
OUT OF THE SENATE.
REFLEX.
THE RECOGNITION THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS ALREADY UPON US AND WE
NEED TO BE DOING FAR MORE TO
PREPARE FOR THE FLOODS AND THE
FIRES IN THE EXTREME HEAT OF AND
THEN WE ARE CURRENTLY DOING TO
AND THIS WAS REFLECTED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS IN THE PROPOSAL COME
OUT OF THE SENATE.
THAT I THINK ARE GOING TO BE
TREMENDOUSLY HELPFUL. FOR YOU
KNOW INVESTING THOSE PROGRAMS TO
DO HELP CREATE A MORE RESILIENT
LANDSCAPE BUT ALSO FOR HELPING
TO BUILD THE CAPACITY.
AND I KNOW YOU MADE SOME CHANGES
THE LAST MOTHER DIDN'T CATCH ALL
OF THE OPEN UNDER A FOLLOW UP ON
BUT SOME OF THOSE OTHER
INVESTMENTS LIKE AT THE NOT TO
RESOURCE AGENCY FOR THEIR
REGIONAL CLIMATE ARE REGIONAL
CAPACITY BUILDING -- THE SORT OF
INVESTMENTS THOSE ARE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL TO ACTUALLY GETTING US
MOVING FORWARD IN SOME OF THESE
PLACES WERE NOT GOING TO GET
THERE JUST BY JAMES AND
TRANSPORTATION AND ENERGY.
WE NEED TO HELP DRIVE SOME OF
THESE CHANGES IN EDUCATION AND
LOCAL PLANNING SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU TO ALL -- NECKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON NO -- KRAMER'S
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION ONE EXPRESS
APPRECIATION TO BOTH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE SENATE.
FOR THE INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR
THE AGRICULTURAL DIESEL ENGINE
REPLACEMENT. NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS IS GREAT.
WE NEED MORE THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK TO BE DONE PARTICULARLY IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY -- WERE
TWELVE THOUSAND TRACTORS NEED TO
BE REPLACEDBY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR AND THESE FUNDS ARE
CRITICAL TO MEETING THAT GOAL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MICHAEL BOOKER ON
BEHALF OF THE AG ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION I WANT TO
FOCUS ONTHE PROVISION LIMITING
THE METHANE REDUCTION FUNDING
FOR DAIRIES.
THE JUST THE AND PROGRAM.
THE DAIRY INDUSTRY SUPPORT OF
BOTH PROGRAMS TO DERRY DIE
JESTER PROGRAM AND THE
ALTERNATIVE MANURE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM I CAN SAY THIS IF
FUNDING IS LIMITED ONLY TO THE
AND PROGRAM WE WILL NOT GET
ANYWHERE NEAR THE LEVEL OF
PRODUCTION THE STATE IS LOOKING.
FOR THAT PROGRAM IS FAR LESS
COST EFFECTIVE THAN THE
DIGESTIVE PROGRAM AND DOES NOT
PROVIDE.
THE CO BENEFITS THAT WE GET FROM
THE DIGEST TO PROGRAM THE DIE
JESTER PROGRAM PROVIDES
SIGNIFICANT.
NOTHING REDUCTIONS AS WELL AS
KNOCKS ANOTHER CRITERIA
POLLUTANT REDUCTIONS THAT'S BEEN
WELL DOCUMENTED BY THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
SO WE'RE VERY TROUBLED IF THIS
MONEY IS IN FACT BEING LIMITED
ONLY TO THE CAMP PROGRAM BECAUSE
IT WILL NOT ALLOW THE STATE TO
ACHIEVE THE REDUCTIONS THE 40%
SOUGHT BY.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT.
JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF LAND
O'LAKES DAIRY -- SHARE THE SAME
CONCERNS AS MR BROKEN ERRO --
DON'T THINK THAT YOU KNOW
LIMITING A TOOL IN THE TOOLS
TOOLBOX FEAR WHICH DIE JESTERS
ARE IN.
REACHING OUR METHANE REDUCTION
GOALS -- IS GOOD POLICY -- WANT
YOU KNOW AS MANY OPTIONS AS
POSSIBLE -- BUT YOU WOULD CREATE
THE INCREASE OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THAT -- MET THEY
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM AND THANK YOU.
CHRIS MARIN BEHALF OF OVERRUN
FUELS APPRECIATE THE SENATE'S
PROPOSED ALLOCATION OF TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS YEAR OF
DOLLARS -- TO ENERGY COMMISSION
FOR LOW CARBON FUEL PRODUCTION.
THANK YOU.
HELLO WORKING NEARBY HAVE
EVERYTHING GO WASTE AND SEE ON
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES IN
SUPPORT OF THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION -- FOR WASTE REDUCTION
AND RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE IS
WANTED TO ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE MADE
EARLIER THANK YOU.
MORNING I JASON BRIDE OF THE OF
THE WESTERN UNITED THURMOND
APPRECIATE OF THE AUGMENTATION
FOR THE G. R. PROGRAM.
WE THINK MORE RESOURCES ARE
FRANKLY NEEDED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE DAIRY INDUSTRY'S ACHIEVING
ITS GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
GOALS AND DO BELIEVE THAT.
THAT THAT MORE OPTIONS THE
BETTER -- FOR OPERATORS WHO ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF ALTERNATE
NOR MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
AND AND A A DIRT I JUST FOR
PROGRAMS UNDER EVEN OR TAKING
VEGETABLES FROM THE SAME JERRY.
IT'S A LIVING OUR TOOLS IS AN
EFFECTIVE WAY TO ACHIEVE THE
OBJECTIVE TO DECREASE THE BUDGET
ALLOCATION AND INCREASE THE
TOOLS THAT.
ARE ABLE TO BE USED.
THANK YOU. FIVE GOOD MORNING --
MISTER CHAIR I THINK IT GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JUST IT'LL FEEL
THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION.
WANTED -- TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
JUST MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE JASON
BRENT ONCE UNITED THURMOND.
ON THE IMPORTANCE OF ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE A PROGRAM THAT
ALLOWS -- FOR AS IT RELATES TO
METHANE REDUCTION LIVESTOCK --
TO THE MOST YOU KNOW EFFICIENT
WAY TO DO IT BOTH FROM A COST
PERSPECTIVE -- AND PRODUCTION
PERSPECTIVE ALSO WANT TO SAY TO
THAT OF MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE FUNDED -- THE METHANE
REDUCTION COMPONENT FOR FOR
LIVESTOCK IS ONE OF THE ONLY ON
ONCE IT'S UNDER A MANDATE -- BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- AND
YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WAS WRITTEN -- IT
IT IS VERY CLEAR IN THERE THAT
THAT PUBLIC FINANCING
SPECIFICALLY THROUGH THE G. R.
PROGRAM HAS TO BE A KEY
COMPONENT OF THIS SO --
APPRECIATE THE WORK THIS
COMMITTEES DOING IN THE FORD
CONTINUING THAT WORK THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANKS.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN WERE IN A
COUPLE DIFFERENT HAS TODAY WANT
TO START WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED BIO FUELS ALLIANCE IN
RECOGNITION OF THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR LOW CARBON PRODUCTION FUELS
A WE HAVE A GROWING RENEWABLE
DIESEL IN BIODIESEL INDUSTRY IN
THE STATE I YET THESE MONIES OF
THE ENERGY COMMISSION REALLY
REALLY HELP WITH WILL NEED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER
ELEMENTS THAT HELP GET THOSE
FUELS.
FROM PRODUCTION TO ACTUAL RETAIL --
AND CONSUMPTION WHICH THEN
LOWERS OUR CLIMATE ARE HELPS OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS IN THE
STATE.
AS IT RELATES TO THE THE
AGRICULTURAL FUNDS.
IN AGREEMENT WITH A LOT OF
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN SAID
APPRECIATE THE NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS PUT TOWARDS THE FARMER
PROGRAM.
THAT THE AIR BE CREATED IN ORDER
TO REDUCE THOSE EMISSIONS IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND EVERYONE
THERE AND EVERYWHERE ELSE AS
RELATES THAT EQUIPMENT.
THIS COMMITTEE IS FOCUSED ON AN
IS TALKED ABOUT THE NEED FOR
METRICS AND THE NEED FOR CLEAR
RESULTS OVER THE YEARS.
REALLY NO OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE
THE FORMER PROGRAM AND THE
METHANE REDUCTION PROGRAM THAT
CAN SHOW YOU THE METRICS.
YOU CAN SHOW YOU THE RESULTS
FROM THE DOLLARS INVESTED.
AND SO WITH THAT BEING SAID IT
KIND OF DRIVES THE QUESTION AS
TO WHY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
METHANE REDUCTION PROGRAM WE
WOULD ONLY SINGLE OUT ONE
TECHNOLOGY.
WE DON'T DO THAT ANYWHERE ELSE
BUT THEY ARE BE WE ALLOW THEM TO
GROUND.
PICK THE BEST TECHNOLOGY TO GET
THE BEST RESULTS WITH THOSE
MONIES YET IN THIS PROPOSAL
WE'RE TELLING CDFA.
WE'RE GONNA TIE YOUR HANDS IN
ONLY GO THROUGH AND FIND ONE
TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
IN ORDER TO MAXIMIZE THE RESULTS
THAT WERE SPEAKING WITH THESE
FUNDS IT WOULD SEEM TO MAKE
SENSE TO ALLOW CFA TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS COME BACK AND SHOW YOU
THE RESULTS.
THAT'S HOW THEY GET THOSE WITH
THOSE MONEY SO WE ASK THAT YOU
DELINK THAT AS YOU MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
PERSEPHONE MORAL HERE ON BEHALF
OF APOLOGY I WERE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR RULES OVER
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION TO CAL
RECYCLE FOR THE WASTE AVERSION
AND WE WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE THANK YOU.
X..
YES GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHAIR
MEMBERS DOUG HOUSTON
REPRESENTING -- FOLKS THAT SORT
OF SPANNED THE STATE INCLUDING
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
MARCIA CONSERVATION.
FORTY CINEMA COUNTY REGIONAL
PARKS SAY THE REDWOODS LEAGUE IN
AND SEE OUR CONSORTIUM ALL VERY
MUCH THE VERY ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT
THE SENATE PROPOSAL AS IT
RELATES TO AYE NATURAL WORKING
LANDS.
THANK YOU THINKING.
ART WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS.
CLEARLY THE SENATE PROPOSAL
LACKS CONTROVERSY.
NO JUST KIDDING [inaudible]
SENATE MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR.
THIS ONE A FOCUS ON A COUPLE OF
ITEMS HERE IN IN FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS ON THAT METHANE
REDUCTION.
I GLAD THAT THE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION IS BACK.
IN.
ON THE ALTERNATE MINIMUM IN AND
IN YOUR MANAGEMENT PROGRAM THIS
REALLY CAN HELP THOSE SMALLER
DAIRIES.
WE TAKE A LOOK AT WHERE THOSE
DIE GESTURES THROUGH THE HELP
ARE GONNA BE LOS LARGER DAIRIES.
IN WHAT WE ALSO KNOW IS AT FOUR
HUNDRED FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
HAS BEEN IVESTED BY THE STATE
OVER TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
INVESTED IN PRIVATE FINDS BE
ABLE TO MATCH THAT.
THE LAST TWO YEARS HAS BEEN
NINETY NINE MILLION INVESTED
WITHIN A BOTH MANURE MANAGEMENT
AS WELL AS THEIR DIE JESTERS.
WE KNOW THAT IT IS ALSO ONE OF
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE TOOLS
THAT WE HAVE.
WHEN IT COMES REDUCING THAT THAT
CARBON FOOTPRINT?
IN WHAT THE CONCERN THAT I HAVE
AS WE MOVE FORWARD IS IT WE HAVE
A MANDATE ON INDUSTRY THAT.
GENERATES ABOUT 8% OF OUR TOTAL
FOOTPRINT.
I EN DID NOW HANDICAPPING ON
ONLY ALLOW ONE ON ONE AREA IN
THIS MANNER MANAGEMENT
[inaudible]
SO I AND WE HAVE YOUR BOX I'M
GRATEFUL THAT WE'VE.
OR AT THE THIRTY FIVE BUT ON
THIS PROGRAM IS ALREADY OVER
PRESCRIBED -- EXCUSE ME
OVERSUBSCRIBED.
COMPARED TO WHERE WE REALLY
SHOULD BE SO I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS AND UNDERSTAND IS GONNA
NEED TO BE ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
HERE -- AS THIS MAKES IT WAY TO
THE LARGER COMMITTEE -- AGAIN I
THINK THE THE BOTTOM LINE IS.
WE HAVE PUT A MANDATE.
UNDERSTANDABLY SO.
ON TO BE ABLE TO REDUCE.
THOSE SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS.
AND I PRIOR TO ACTUALLY ROLLING
OUT WHAT THAT REDUCTION PLANS
GOING TO BE OR CUTTING BACK THE
FUNDING.
AND NOT PUTTING THE FLEXIBILITY
AS WE TRADITIONALLY HAD OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS THE FIRST YEAR
WE HAD FIFTY MILLION THE LAST.
TWO EIGHT NINETY NINE THE STILL
HAS.
REAL CONCERNS -- IN REGARDS TO
THAT.
IN I THINK THAT THIS IS GOING TO
NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE.
GREATER DISCUSSION BUT WITHIN
BUDGET SUB.
THE OTHER ITEM I WILL SAY IS
ALSO.
HAPPENED WILL SEE THE EREKLE TO
DIESEL ENGINE REPLACEMENT AND
UPGRADE PROGRAM BACK IN THE
NINETY MILLION.
IS THAT IS CRITICAL TO BE ABLE
TO MEET THE NEEDS PARTICULARLY
IN RURAL AND AGRICULTURAL
CALIFORNIA.
IS WELL SO I JUST APPRECIATE
THAT JUST WANTED TO COMMENT ON
THE METHANE REDUCTION SIMPLY
BECAUSE I THINK THAT WE ARE --
SURELY MANY CONSTRAINTS UNDER
THAT PROGRAM THERE'S STILL MORE
WORK TO COME.
THANK CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT -- TO
SHARE THOSE CONCERNS AS WELL.
ALTHOUGH I DON'T HAVE IT IN MY
DISTRICT I DON'T THINK I MEAN
LARGE JERRY'S BUT I DO HAVE
SEVERAL SMALLER A SPECIALTY
DERRY'S -- YOU KNOW SO I AM KIND
OF UP TO SPEED A LITTLE BIT ON
THE INDUSTRY.
THE LARGE DIE GESTURES SEEM TO
BE AN IMPORTANT ASPECT TO ME I
AM ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE DROP
FROM -- YOU KNOW NEARLY A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS -- TO YOU KNOW
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THIS
YEAR MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DOES NOT
PRESCRIBE HOW IT -- THE THIRTY
FIVE MILLION IS TO BE SPENT --
YOU KNOW SO I AGREE WITH SISTER
MCGUIRE THAT WE GRANT HAS
MEDICINAL CONVERSATIONS ON ON
HOW THAT'S BEING.
DIVIDED UP [inaudible] ONE FOUR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS.
TRYING TO FOUND FIND THE RIGHT
BALANCE HERE IT IS A PROCESS.
I ALSO JUST WANT TO FOCUS IN ON
THE RESTORATION OF THE
AGRICULTURAL DIESEL ENGINE
REPLACEMENT UPGRADES.
HEAR LOUD AND CLEAR THAT.
WE COULD USE MORE.
ABOUT HAVING THIS BACK IN THE
BUDGET -- CERTAINLY HELPS US
MOVE FORWARD -- WITH THESE
OBJECTIVES.
I ALSO SHARE THE CONCERNS
INVOICE DONE THE METHANE.
REDUCTION -- BUT I AM GLAD TO
SEE THAT WE HAVE THE M. P. SEVEN
BACK IN THE BUDGET.
I ALSO WANT TO THINK.
THE CHAIR FOR PROTECTING.
THE S. SORRY -- BACK FILL IS
IMPORTANT TO OUR RURAL AREAS SAN.
BOTH IN TERMS OF FIRE PREVENTION.
SUPPRESSION BUT ALSO RELIEVING --
RESIDENTS AND TAXPAYERS WERE
PAYING IN MANY CASES TO A LOCAL
FIRE DISTRICT.
AS WELL AS EARLIER -- IN CHARGE
OF THE S. SORRY FUNDS SO --
AGAIN A WORK IN PROGRESS BUT I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR.
FOR HIS RESILIENCE AN ADAPTATION
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THERE YOU HAVE IT I THINK THAT.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS EACH YEAR.
TO DECIDE WHAT THE SENATE AND
WHAT THE ASSEMBLY AND WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS ARE TO
SPEND GREENHOUSE GASES.
I WOULD BE REMISS IF I DID NOT.
SAY THAT MY ATTENTION GOING
FORWARD IS GOING TO BE AT AT
WHAT PRICE WE SELL -- ALLOWANCES
I'VE SAID ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS
THAT THE PRICE. FOR CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS FOR GENERAL CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS WHETHER IT'S A
CEMENT PLANT OR A OR REFINERY IS
ABOUT TEN AND A HALF PERCENT IS
WHAT THE AGGREGATED NUMBER IS
AND THE TRANSLATION OF WHAT THE
GREENHOUSE GAS.
ALLOWANCES OURS ABOUT SEVEN AND
A HALF PERCENT YOU DON'T NEED TO
BE IN THE CON MIS UNDERSTAND THE
CHEAPER NOW TO PAY FO THE
ALLOWANCES FOR THE GET THEM FREE.
GET THEM FREE AND TO DO THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THE REDUCE THE
GREENHOUSE GASES SO WHILE I AYE
AYE.
THIS IS OUR JOB HERE YOU GO
THROUGH THE BUDGET.
AND THE SPENT THEM THE REAL
DISCUSSION NEEDS TO OCCUR I'M
WHAT.
WHAT WILL CALIFORNIA IN THEIR
OPTION WHAT PRICE WILL THEY?
WILL THEY SAID FOR THIS FOR THE
SALE OF ALLOWANCES THAT POLLUTED
AND I'VE HEARD.
LOUD AND CLEAR PEOPLE THAT THE
AUTHOR DIDN'T GET MONEY -- AND
HOW THESE OF HOW THESE FUNDS
COULD BE -- SPEND WE KNOW THAT
AB SIX SEVENTEEN AB. THREE
NINETY EIGHT FOR SAYS TO TO SET
UP A A A A SYSTEM ON THE ADD ON
THE GREENHOUSE GASES AND SOME OF
THE ADVOCATES FOR THE PROGRAM
NOW WERE AGAINST.
THE THE EIGHTH LEGISLATION AT
THE TIME BECAUSE WE KNEW IT HAD
A CRUSHING.
PRICE SO THAT'S MY COMMITMENT
INTO THE OTHER COMMITMENTS THAT
WE HAVE IN AT THIS TIME WE WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
SO MOVED BY CENTER JONES PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
WIRE [inaudible]
MONEY.
OKAY LET'S MOVE THE ISSUE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN THIS WILL BE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE.
THIS IS THE UNCLAIMED GAS TAX --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
[inaudible]
GO.
SO YOU WANT TO RETAIN A PORTION
OF THE REMAINING -- AND CLIMB
GAS TAX.
CORRECT IN AND GET AFTERNOON
SENATOR -- AND AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JENNY
LESSER MOFFETT I'M
UNDERSECRETARY AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE.
AND WE'RE HERE -- TO REQUEST
SUCH TRADE CHANGES THAT WILL
PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY IN HOW WE
SPEND ADDITIONAL MONEY THAT IS
ALLOCATED.
THE UNCLAIMED GAS TAX -- BY THIS
SB DUE TO SB.
ONE I THE LANGUAGE ALLOWS WILL
ALLOW CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE TO EXPAND
THAT PORTION OF THE INCREASED
UNCLAIMED GAS TAX.
BASED ON AN AGREEMENT WITH US
AND THE CALIFORNIA I
COMMISSIONERS.
ASSOCIATION.
WE'RE DELIGHTED THAT YOU HAVE
SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WHAT
TYPE OF FLEXIBLE OR PROGRAMS --
DO YOU EXPECT TO BE SPENDING
THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDS ON THAT
THAT MAY BE HELPFUL FOR THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO UNDERSTAND.
RIGHT OZ SO.
CURRENTLY A LOT OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE FUNDED THROUGH THE
ONLINE GAS TAX GO TO THE BIGGER
JOURNAL GENERAL AG ACTIVITIES SO
THEY MIGHT BE THINGS LIKE.
I PROTECTING PLANT AND ANIMAL
HEALTH.
THROUGH -- OUR QUARANTINE
TRAPPING SYSTEMS THAT WERE DOING
ON THE SEAS.
I IT ALSO GOES TOWARDS WEED
MANAGEMENT -- REALLY LOOKING AT
SOME HOLISTIC APPROACHES THAT
WERE WORKING ON TO PROTECT
AGRICULTURE AS A WHOLE.
THIS FUNDING I RIGHT NOW AS IT
AS ALLOCATED AS IT IS DESCRIBED
IN THE CURRENT.
STATUTE -- IS VERY SPECIFIC AND
HOW THE MONEY IS ALLOCATED THE
ADDITIONAL MONIES.
GO TOWARD.
THAT STRAIGHT TO THE COUNTY AYE
COMMISSIONERS TO THE COUNTIES.
WHAT THAT COUNTY AG
COMMISSIONERS HAVE DISCUSSED
WITH US IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THAT DEPARTMENT TO RETAIN SOME
OF THOSE MONIES TO DO?
BROADER STRAIGHT STATEWIDE
INITIATIVE SUCH AS AS SEE WHAT I
AM DOING MORE OF A STATEWIDE
SEQUEL OUT LOOK -- ON BEHALF OF
THE WORK THAT THE AYE
COMMISSIONERS ARE DOING
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
I'M A LEO.
YOU HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THE
LANGUAGE I WAS HOPING THE PUBLIC
HEARING THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN THE INCLINE GAS TAX
FOR FOOD AND AGRICULTURE -- OUR
MANAGER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL IN
SUPPORT OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
THAT IS ALL WE HONOR WE HAVE A
COVER GRAY TO FEED CALIFORNIA C.
TO SENSATIONALIZE WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE THE BILL LANGUAGE
THANK YOU.
RIGHT WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS QUESTIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
THERE'S A MOTION TO APPROVE
RECOMMENDATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
HI.
MY RUNNING.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU VOTE THE
AYES HAVE A FIVE ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS -- WE ARE
ADJOURNED UNTIL WERE CALLED BACK
[inaudible]
WE'RE TURN